jimmy let me give you an idea how scary
it gets i i have a friend that i've
known for over 40 years he was my
closest friend he has a son with special
needs
and he's convinced that donald trump
quote mocked a disabled reporter there
was a poll in 2016 before the election
the number one reason likely voters gave
for not wanting to vote for donald trump
is because he allegedly mocked a
disabled reporter
the story was because donald trump said
there were people who were cheering the
fall of the twin towers
and to be sure there was a reporter who
wrote a story about that when the people
asked the reporter about the story he
backed away from it yeah
and donald trump mocked him backing away
from it began shaking like this i don't
remember i don't know so more like
mocking him in like a power right back
peddling there's a website called
catholics for trump
uh and there are several videos where
donald trump has used that gesture to
mock himself to mock an able-bodied
person and furthermore the reporter in
question his name is serge kovaleski
doesn't go like this right he has an
atrophy he has a some sort of disease he
has an atrophied arm but he doesn't
shake like this he speaks very calmly
and very evenly so he wasn't even doing
an impression of him
and i sent my friend a three-page letter
jamie with with a link to catholics for
trump to show him that he's wrong
and my friend by the way had a perfect
score in his s.a.t yeah close to perfect
score on his lsat he's brilliant and it
didn't matter and i had an epiphany i
found out that people who hate donald
trump did not want to unhate him had
nothing to do with intelligence it was
all emotion and this guy was invested in
disliking donald trump invested in this
story it is not true so i have a
question you are and we ended our
friendship he's like he ended it so what
i was going to say what i crazy what i
respect you for that interaction is you
reached out right and you tried to write
the three-page letter so i guess my
question is i've known you for a half an
hour yeah or however longer yeah
it's a lot longer fake news everybody uh
i've been pitching them bits uh and the
you know you seem like a you you've been
very kind and intelligent and i've
learned things my question is then how
does someone and this is like an honest
question is
how would you if we're trying to avoid
civil war which seems like i don't know
a priority um
how does the right
how do you especially as like a public
figure
kind of try to not turn into
that same tribalized left how can you
or is it even your responsibility try to
get your fans to reach out but he's not
i mean quite literally if his whole
point is that he reads the facts to
figure out what's true right and someone
else doesn't you don't need to avoid
doing it you're just not doing it no but
what i'm saying is like
do people like us and i'm even counting
myself being on this show do we sort of
need to go above and beyond to instead
of just attacking attacking attacking
try to get the other side to see the
facts in a compassionate way like you
attempted with your friend and then it's
on your friend that he didn't respond
the problem is one side and i'm
generalizing obviously one side the left
believes the right is not just wrong
they're bad people if not evil we
believe at least i believe people on the
left are ill-informed uh and need to be
better educated but i don't con i don't
dismiss them as evil bad people i have a
recent friend leftist is all get out
name is jackie
jackie jackie hates donald trump and
believes donald trump engaged in an
interaction a coup so i sent her an
article written by uh
uh alan dershowitz who is a left-wing
professor voted twice for obama but been
very fair and very even on this issue
and he talked about the the 911
commission
committee how unfair it was how
one-sided it was that donald trump in
his speech said i want you to
patriotically and peacefully go over and
make your voices heard on and on very
very well argued i sent it to her texted
to her yeah
she texts back right away and says uh
this is garbage i wrote back and i said
you could not have possibly read it
in that time that you text back to me so
she refused to even read the information
what do you want me to do i wouldn't
open the window and just start yelling i
mean liberals are very fast readers this
is where i got i want to push back i
think this is a mistake that uh the
right often makes the saying is the
right thinks the left is ill-informed
the left thinks the right is evil in
fact i think the left is the example of
the banality of evil and it doesn't
matter if it's left or right any kind of
historical context
let's just call it blue and red or a and
b
whatever it is when you've got
libertarians
uh post liberal disaffected liberal
conservative republican whatever on one
side disparate ideologies people
disagree having a conversation and then
you have people who are driven by
emotion won't even bother to read the
facts you're dealing with a cult you are
dealing with the banality of evil they
are engaging in evil actions to evil
ends
for no specific reason they don't need
to have intent
if a person
is you know look
if a person grabs a weapon and thinks
they're a good guy and like actually
i'll tell you a story right now there's
a viral story
where a guy murdered his neighbors
because he said they were using
telepathy to mind control him
yeah he's crazy he is a he is a he
committed an evil act but his intent was
skewed by nonsense that doesn't change
the fact that what he did was evil so
i'm not going to call them ill-informed
i'm going to say they're engaged and not
right engaged and not right evil okay
well i do want to that's fair enough my
mother was a lifelong democrat my
brother my best friend was a lifelong
democrat i never considered them to be
evil i considered them to be
ill-informed and i worked on them and i
got them to vote for george w bush twice
my mother voted for ronald reagan they
wouldn't change their party because that
was emotion but i was able to reason
with them so i don't dismiss all of them
but you're quite right you take up
somebody like jeff zucker the former
head of cnn he's on tape project veritas
has people on tape
at cnn producers saying that in our nine
o'clock meeting every morning with jeff
zucker jeff ducker hates donald trump
has a vendetta against donald trump and
he wants us to do anti-trump stories to
the to the exclusion of other news
that's evil that's villain that's
villainy well and to your point about
your family i feel like my job here
today is to stop a civil war um instead
of promote my gigs um to your point i'm
really glad you brought up your family
because what i was gonna say
and i'm not disagreeing with you guys a
ton but i want to say that
twitter liberals
uh
antifa liberals
media liberals are far different than
and same with conservatives than the
people i meet at jitsu who we're all
hanging out we don't care about
political parties maybe people on the
left are like yeah i'm liberal because
like i don't care if gay people marry
and i'm against the war and that's kind
of all they know they're not on twitter
they're not trying to stir stuff up they
barely know about january 6th nor does
that care about it i had a meeting with
a friend in new york and when i tried
explaining to him that democrats tried
to legalize abortion up to the point of
birth he said that's impossible that
can't be true and i said if you are
actively speaking out this person with a
high profile platform in defense of
their bill without having read it
because you can't believe that i would
be right at all even though you didn't
read it that's the banality of evil when
people engage in evil actions and it's
become a normal process
what i don't understand though man is
like i'm an artist which means legally i
have to hate myself so i cannot be a
special case i cannot be the only person
that went in a room with you guys here's
something i don't know and go oh damn i
never thought of it that way i feel like
there are other people out there like
during the debates bernie sanders was
specifically asked
do you believe that there's a point
beyond which an abortion is murder i
don't know and he basically said no
uh and when i was running for governor
uh the texas so-called fetal uh
heartbeat bill got passed and i was
asked over and over again about abortion
because i'm pro-life and i said would
you just ask my opponent gavin newsom
just one time at one point does he feel
that pregnancy has gone so far that it
would be then become become murder and
they never ask him and his position is
up to including the moment before before
birth although larry i can say if we
disagree on everything else the rest of
the show we can agree and become friends
on the fact that i too do not like gavin
newsom
he's got great hair though
he's so happy but he looks like american
psycho you know regarding the banana
it's the basements in the body it's come
up a few times about accusing people of
being the banality of evil tim you have
actually called me the banality of evil
multiple times but i think that like
this is true i'm never stuck we're
supporting
slavery in china that's getting us this
cheap technology like my my cell phone
was only 600 bucks instead of 1150
because it was made by chinese slaves we
have factory farming like that's not
evil that's evil to do that to animals
and but we live that that's part of our
existence we are the banality of evil as
americans we are fascists and that's
just part of the game right now i just i
disagree so my point on the banality of
evil is an individual who's taking
direct action that is evil uh this is an
interesting point if you if you've ever
watched the show the good place yeah
it's one of my favorite things they make
the point that life has become so
complicated it's impossible to get into
the good place basically heaven because
no matter what you do you're doing
something bad you you buy some flowers
for a friend to cheer them up well those
flowers have pesticides which is killing
bees which came from slave labor
i can understand the complexities of
human life on the planet
and like you mentioned sweatshop labor
and all those things
but there could be people who are
actively opposed to that speaking out
against it and trying to stop it the
difference is when you cheer on and vote
for intentionally
rating that being weaponized to go after
people and destroy
that's very different it concerns me
because well at least i was taught like
that's not good you don't want to
support the evil that you're trying you
don't want to use evil to destroy evil
it doesn't work like that you become the
evil you're trying to end
um but i don't know if everybody was
raised like that and if they weren't
then i can't like maybe the banana but
the
they're banal is that the right word it
is now but i'm talking about two
different things
we're talking about two different things
though
i agree with you there is an issue that
we all kind of just churn along not
realizing that uh the computers we have
are made by people who are you know
foxconn labs when they're committing
mass suicide and things like that those
are all really bad and for a lot of
people like i immediately stopped using
iphones when i found out about that
granted a lot of components they'll come
from those factories but i was like i
didn't know i didn't know and when i
learned i said i have to change that i
can't get mad at you for the green
bubbles anymore but when it comes to
what's happening with what you know
larry's talking about trying to let them
know they say i don't care that's the
difference yeah
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm we'll see you all there
you